[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Sarah wolfkind
who stars in Grim Cutty which is out now
on Hulu so we're gonna be talking
spoilers so make sure you watch the film
first how you doing today Sarah
I'm doing really well
um we were just talking about my dead
plant
um which needs to be watered soon yeah I
I love your dead plant
um but you're bringing life to it by
just sitting there so
I I am so excited to talk to you bring
life to this film with grim Cuddy now we
see with your character of Asha
she does ASMR are you in real life a fan
of ASMR you ever done ASMR
um I did not attempt ASMR before this
film
um I remember like I watched like
crushing videos like those are really
satisfying on Instagram and it makes you
really tingly
um but no I'm the director John Ross he
actually he I was on set he was like
yeah you're gonna have to do ASMR right
handed me this microphone he was like
this is a really good microphone I would
try doing ASMR on it any reference some
videos to me but
um yeah first time oh wow so first time
I mean that seemed like the pro was
doing it so Props to you uh you should
probably consider it one day
um now did you see this terrifying Grim
Cuddy monster right away on set and is
it exactly what it looks like on screen
as it is in person
um
I was having meetings with the director
and then he showed me like the photo
first I'm like oh okay that's that's
cool
um and then it was like first on set
um you know I haven't actually seen the
film yet oh okay okay a little bit in
like ADR sessions and I've seen it in
the trailer
um but I haven't seen it I feel like it
pretty much looks the same because we
use practical effects but yeah the first
time I saw it was on set it was a little
bit jarring at first and like oh there
he is
um I think he pretty much looked the
same it was like a little bit more
aliveness to it um in the film
yeah I mean it looks awesome and it's
really scary and of course that's so
important for a Creature Feature like
this now did you see any inspiration
from Momo for Grim Cuddy do you kind of
see that connection I didn't okay I
didn't know what the Momo challenge was
before this and then um John explained
it to me
um and then I started to see it and then
I searched it up I'm like that's
disturbing yeah yeah John actually based
um he got inspiration from Momo he was
watching the news and like the kids and
parents reaction to the Momo challenge
were different so um and that's how he
created Grim Cutty oh I love that yeah I
definitely saw that inspiration and I
remember that terrifying me a couple
years ago as well so for you though were
you I think a lot of people always
wonder with like the lead actress of
some of this were you ever scared in any
of the scenes on set or does that not
really happen here
um in terms of like acting wise yeah
like in any of those moments were you
really scared at all ever that ever
happened oh yeah on set I was
um there was like some scenes like it
was like 100 degrees out and I was like
I don't know what I'm doing and I would
I would go to Shannon Shannon Sossaman
who plays my mom I would be like Shannon
I don't know what I'm doing like I don't
know if I'm doing anything right and
then also Tate Moore on set like we
became really close and we're best
friends now and I was like I was like I
don't know what I'm doing she's like
you're doing fine
um but yeah it was really just like a
trial and error experience
um I learned a lot yeah no you did
amazing and um yeah and it's interesting
too I was going to ask you did that feel
like did you always know it was going to
be something that goes on Hulu like did
you feel an amount of pressure being in
the lead and something that's going to
be on this big streaming service
um a little bit but I feel like for the
most part I just tried to focus on the
work because that's like all I could do
um yeah on set I feel like onset is like
so not glamorous at all and then like
who lose like this big thing so I was
like I'm just gonna focus on what's
right in front of me I'm gonna try and
do my best work and I feel like that's
where the pressure came from I think
mainly from myself rather than like Hulu
you know yeah no totally and yeah you do
awesome job and it's so interesting this
film because a lot of like very
relatable things that are in the now
today like it's very modern and one of
those things I thought was interesting
was the detox box do you think this is a
concept that you would actually ever use
you think it works do you think there's
some use like adults could have for this
um
huh I feel like
if you make something official like the
detox box is like becomes this thing
that kids just don't want to do but I
feel like once in a while it's okay be
like hey let's just like get away from
like technology now because I know that
a lot of people benefit from that
um I think it can be helpful I just
don't think
maybe it's something that a person has
to choose to get the benefits from it
otherwise they're just gonna be thinking
about their phone all the time
um but yeah like once in a while like I
put down my phone I'm like wow I haven't
I've gone this long without my phone how
did I do it but I feel better so I think
there could be benefits yeah yeah for
sure and and since she mentioned the
phones and how this commentary in this
room about tech and do you kind of agree
with maybe a statement that like the
film's also saying that like even our
use of technology is more scary than
even the actual monster in this film
um I would
yeah I would say so because
Technologies and all that and I feel
like we have like such an ultra Reliance
on technology and
um like things are created through
technology and inspiring information is
spread throughout technology
um so yeah I feel like if everything
like went dead one day then where would
we be right
um because yeah it happened so much to
just using it
um so yes
yeah no for sure that that's a great
answer and uh yeah it is interesting and
I think it's interesting for someone
like me who's now 30 watching this and
kind of I don't have children so seeing
kind of how kids and teens are using
technology now is always fascinating me
so I'm happy this film kind of delved
into that now I also love the ending
here and you have your narration and
we're kind of starting to get like the
whole theme of the movie towards the end
and I kind of want you to elaborate
about what the film's kind of saying
about
you know communication between parents
and their children if you can kind of
maybe go into what the point of the film
is trying to say about that
yeah I feel like there's this thing
between like
parents and their kids where it's like
their kids are their own person and I
think like I feel like parents have to
get to know their kids rather than just
being like oh they're a product of me
um which I don't think the parents in
this film do but
um
but yeah I think
I think that there has to be like a real
communication
um especially like the generation like
kids are more attuned to their
technology and just like listening to
one another and like trusting one
another and that they have especially
teenagers like they're their own person
um I think is really important yeah yeah
I I totally agree with that and I love
that and I really love that message
that's in this film now you Sarah are
you a fan of the horror genre in general
what's really funny is like growing up I
was it's scared of everything I was like
no I can't but it's like wasn't until
recently that I started watching uh more
horror films my friend she brought me to
Halloween Horror Nights last year and we
also
um and then I was like I was like I'm
gonna be so scared she was like you'll
be fine I was like I actually like being
scared
um so then I started watching like more
horror movies um she got me into a lot
of body horror uh more than like jumpy
scare horror so
um yeah I've been getting into that a
little bit more that's awesome is there
any in this time of you watching Horror
in general it was there any maybe scream
queens that you know inspired your
performance for this and he kind of
performance as you looked at
before and like growing up my parents
are like why are you always screaming
um
no I think um just like the script
itself just like had so much information
in it and like things you can like dig
out and
like certain like tones and like
textures and things you can feel
um so yeah I just like kind of generate
that on my own yeah no for sure and
you're you're an awesome scream Queen
which I'm excited about and also what's
great about this film too is having this
you know big bad and Grim Cuddy and I
think that's kind of iconic in a way for
you though was there any hard big bads
you prefer or like a lot like whether
it's Pennywise Jason Freddy is there any
that he thinks maybe your favorite
um I don't think I have a favorite
no
I was like thinking like what was I
scared of growing up I don't know no
yeah look
that's totally totally fine yeah I think
that like it's so tough to pick between
those two because they're also iconic
you know so but I think that like this
film Grim kruddy again it's just gonna
make people want to see more of this
character too and more of your
performance so
I think on that note what can people be
excited for next for Sarah wolfkind what
could we see you in next or anything
coming up or anything you do podcast
book anything oh my gosh imagine if I
wrote a book I believe
working with drum Cuddy
um
I love it
um no I feel like I'm just I'm just
working for the next thing um nothing's
lined up yet
um I'm always down to do horror again I
love horror like acting in it more
um
I love screaming I love the high stake
situation so I'll be open to that but
yeah nothing lined up yet just
and grinding at it no and you did
amazing here and everyone just keep
watching this film it's on Hulu watch
Sarah just absolutely crush it Sarah
thank you so much for joining me today
and I'll pray for your dead plant
um oh thank you my thoughts and uh I
hope it's hard to get in the future one
day yeah you too Steve